hello everyone and welcome to the last
game we'll be showing from round two of
this year's Tata steel chess tournament
it is Jordan pest versus max maram both
of them locals um Dutch Grand Masters
and it's a really wild game of the
London system where both players have an
incredibly active Bishop pair there sort
of the the game is a fight of whose
Bishop pair becomes um fully operational
sooner so let's check it out quite a
battle Jordan with the white pieces
opens with Pawn to D4 we have Pawn to D5
by Max uh Knight to F3 Knight to F6 and
Bishop to F4 the London system or the
so-called accelerated London system we
have Bishop to F5 going for the
symmetrical variation E3 E6 and now
Knight B to D2 Max continues um going
symmetrical Knight B to D7 and now Pawn
to C4 and for those of you who are maybe
new to chess uh you know it's a fair
question why wouldn't black just
continue uh symmetrical every move uh
the problem is there is a the existence
of of check in chess and that makes it a
problem so to give you a quick example
if uh let's say you continue
symmetrically captures captures captures
captures now white would play e captures
and D7 with check and uh well due to the
existence of check black is unable to
play uh e captur on D2 you have to deal
with the pawn first and then you're just
down a piece at the end of this line so
if there was no check you know it'd be
possible but then you'd run into
Checkmate and so on but okay D captures
on C4 he takes the pawn uh Bishop
captures and now Bishop to D6
transposing not transposing going into
the game that n abasov played with the
white pieces against Magnus Carlson in
last year's fiday World Cup uh so Knight
the E5 and now Knight to E4 putting
pressure on the Knight Here pawn to F3
kicking away the Knight white gains full
control over the center here Knight
captures Queen captures and now Queen to
E7 in the game abaso versus Carlson
Carson continued with Pawn to F6 and
that game ended in a draw but here we
have Queen to E7 by Max and it is now as
of move 10 that we have a completely new
game uh so okay both players Castle
Queen side uh and now Queen to A5 a bit
of an odd Square for the White Queen
usually you're used to the queen being
on D1 and then having access only to
light squares uh but yeah here Queen A5
just puts pressure on that A7 pawn and
uh you have to figure out how to do uh
what to do here you could play King to
B8 uh but it is better to First
eliminate the Knight on E5 so Knight
captures on E5 Pawn captures attacking
the bishop and the A7 pawn and of course
Bishop to C5 just defending the A7 Pawn
we have Pawn to E4 uh Bishop to G6 and
now Pawn to A3 uh creating some breeding
room for the king maybe you can get the
king later on to A2 but also B4 in the
future might be an idea so Bishop to B6
we have Queen back to C3 and now King to
B8 getting the King off of the C file uh
and now comes Pawn to G3 you could
consider some other moves like maybe
King to B1 but it looks Odd as the
bishop is on this diagonal and then
maybe you're just inviting Pawn to F5
but even with Pawn to G3 uh Max does go
for Pawn to F5 he wants to open up this
diagonal and keep the white king uh sort
of in the center of the board where it
can be accessed by by the bishop by the
rook and well all in all it's a great
Bishop uh so here we have e captures on
F6 alasan G R and now Pawn to E5 this is
a very strange move uh as for the moment
your queen and Bishop are very very
strong pieces but by playing Pawn to E5
uh it uh well it's hard to say what um
Jordan wanted to do here uh it's a move
that if it works tactically of course
it's great you are putting pressure on
F6 and then uh for example if Pawn to F5
is played you can play Pawn to H4 with
the threat of Bishop G5 uh does seem to
be very impressive and then if captures
captures point is that you will not be
able to play Rook d8 uh because Rook
captures Queen captures and you lose the
E6 pawn and if you want to keep the E6
Pawn then white will get control over
the dile pretty much for the rest of the
game once you play Bishop to G5 kick
away the queen put the bishop on F6 you
will have control over that d8 square uh
but um the problem is he doesn't go for
Pawn to F5 he just plays Queen to C5 and
he gives up the E6 pawn and uh what do
you play here uh well uh Jordan decided
to capture on E6 and you could try some
other moves um he decided to go for
Bishop captures on E6 uh uh F captures
on E5 and now Queen captures on C5 we
have Bishop captures and now you see the
problem of uh the white king being stuck
in the center you cannot capture on E5
because Bishop to E3 check and Black's
Bishop pair became fully operational
before White's Bishop pair even though
it's very impressive uh the game is just
over here there's no defense Rook D2 has
to be played and then you just take the
the the free rook and you're very close
to
checkmating uh the white king uh and
another thing uh after this
bishop uh sorry after this um Bishop
captures and C5 move is that if you play
uh well what can you play if you play
Rook captures on d8 first uh Rook
captures and then you play Bishop back
to D2 uh yes this is possible but it's
uh it does seem to be a very very
passive position Rook can come to D6
attack the bishop here once the bishop
moves and it's hard to say where where
you want to move the bishop if you move
it to to B3 it's in the way of your B
Pawn if you move it to C4 then it's also
just in front of the white king you can
even play something like Bishop captures
on A3 it's hard to say whether it would
be enough for black to win the game but
it's um uh definitely a much better
position here you already have a a pass
SE Point you're probably going to create
another one here on the queen side it
would be black playing for the win here
uh and uh other than that there really
aren't any uh great moves here but
Bishop to H6 was played which is uh well
which is a really really poor move by uh
by Jordan uh and you have to take
advantage of it so Bishop to D4 uh just
putting pressure on that B2 pawn and
also making room for The Rook to enter
the game and now as the Bishops are
incredibly strong here what's uh what's
the defense against Rook to D6 followed
by Rook to C6 check uh there just
doesn't appear to be any Bishop to B3
was played uh but now the move that um
well uh we've been talking about for the
entire game I could ask you to pause the
video here but you already know Rook to
D6 is coming uh so Rook to D6 was played
and now uh what can the white king do
it's uh such a scary scary spot to be in
facing those dragons uh if if you try
running away with the King you're hoping
for something like Bishop captures on B2
okay you give up a pawn maybe your king
survives uh King comes to B6 that's the
problem attacks the bishop uh not much
to do here you can move the bishop uh
Rook captures and B2 with check King to
E1 uh The Rook will come to d8 and it's
uh well what can you do Bishop F2 check
for example Rook captures on D1 uh this
is a disaster and another thing if you
maybe go Rook to D2 you try and give
your king the D1 Square also doesn't
really work Rook to C6 check King to D1
and now okay you could go for Rook to B6
like in the previous line but you could
also Play Bishop H5 uh also very very
strong and the point is if Pawn to G4
there's just Rook captures on H6 also
one of the problems of Jordan's Bishop
on H6 and then after G captures you just
repeat Rook to B6 go after the bishop
here if King to C2 now you bring the
other Rook into the game and okay Rook
to f one can be played but uh your your
position is just terrible uh it's only a
matter of time before black wins this so
instead after Rook to D6 Rook captures
and D4 was played Yan tried the in
exchange sacrifice e captures on D4 of
course you have to accept it and now
Bishop to D1 uh guarding that F3 Pawn
against the threat of Bishop to H5 so
Rook to E8 and now Pawn to H4 we have
Rook to C6 with check King to D2 and now
Rook to B6 going after the B2 Pawn we
have King back to C1 and here we have a
repetition for a few moves Rook back to
B6 King to C1 but now Max of course does
not want a draw by three-fold repetition
he will push for the win Pawn to C5 uh
Pawn to H5 attacking the bishop Bishop
to D3 we have Bishop to G7 now finally
the bishop gets activated and Bishop to
E2 there were some other moves like Rook
to E3 which were probably more precise
uh but uh Bishop D2 was played here and
now even with uh the absolute best move
it's still a difficult position for
white for example if Rook D1 uh okay The
Rook on E8 is undefended but you can
just play Rook B to E6 and again Pawn to
F4 will be played uh very very hard
position for uh for white but okay you
might have some counter playay here you
you can't really uh play G4 but you have
F5 F6 coming so uh this was your your
best option but he played F4 right away
and now just Bishop captures on D1 we
Rook captures on D1 and now Rook to B3
putting pressure on the G3 Pawn so
Bishop to E5 with check cutting of the
uh d8 Rook from entering the game King
to C8 and now Rook to G1 defending the
pawn on G3 and okay you might have
something here the bishop controls the
Rook if you have G4 G5 G6 you create a
pass Pawn maybe some F5 F6 action uh all
of a sudden it might be white playing
for the win here uh but Rook to G8 of
course you're not going to allow Pawn to
G4 uh but it still happens Pawn to G4
and now Rook to H3 showing that pawn to
G4 was not really uh relevant as now
Rook captures on H5 is the threat if
Pawn captures The Rook on G1 is
undefended and and um you don't really
have a way of dealing with this King to
D2 was played and uh while you could
play Rook captures on H5 uh he just
plays King to D7 and now Pawn to G5 we
have King to E6 the king is now uh in
the game Pawn to B4 and now Pawn to C4
and he was in this position on move 40
upon reaching time control that Jordan
pest resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here so a really
tough loss for him after losing um round
one to Ala as well uh the problem is of
course the pawn cannot be captured if
the pawn is captured then this just wins
material here and if you can't take that
what else can you play well okay we
could show you a fun line let's say you
just play for the win here uh King to D5
let's say you play G7 okay uh Pawn to C3
check King to C2 King to C4 with check
and now you're going to play F5 let's
say Pawn to D3 with check King to B1
King to B3 and now okay F6 is coming
you're very close to getting two of your
pawns to theeven seventh rank uh but now
Pawn to D2 and there's uh not much you
can do here one C2 check lands that's
pretty much it so you're going to have
to take um a pawn here in order to
eliminate the the past pawns let's say
Rook captures and now you're going to
play Rook to D1 uh but now just Rook G
to C8 and okay white could get some play
here but it's nothing really now if you
capture the pawn of course Rook to C1 is
m in one if you don't then just Rook to
C1 with check Rook captures and Rook
Capt will be Checkmate so there's really
nothing to try here you don't have time
for F7 you don't have time for G8 looks
very nice but that's all there is uh so
yeah after Pawn to C4 uh uh Jordan
resigned and a very nice victory for Max
vadam and the results after as only two
rounds have been played ala is on Full
two points and on a point and a half
it's GES Yani pishi and Anish giri with
all the rest of follow and you haven't
seen my previous videos uh these these
are the the the well the results of
round two so abdat Drew against pran Yan
Drew against women's world champion ju
WJON it was a really uh really fight a
nice fighting game uh much like her game
against Anish giri in round one which
she lost but yeah against Yan she was
able to to hold the draw um even though
uh in the end game it was her it was her
who had opponent Advantage but didn't
really make any difference Anish giri
versus V to draw uh so I guess they
remain friends Wei versus GES we've seen
that game GES took a victory there ala
defeated makulu we also checked out that
game yesterday uh ding Len a draw for
the world champion against Alexander
donchenko uh so was pretty strange as
ding did have the white pieces everyone
was expecting a win here and we we have
yet to see ding winning a gameing
classical you know since becoming world
champion uh you know in in recent times
and yon vanz versus max V Max won a very
nice game here uh so yeah just a cool
London system game with both players
having a really active Bishop pair only
Max's Bishop pair was uh much more fully
operational uh so that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it very much looking
forward to round three uh I would like
to thank Welsh fan Mark Henley Brennan
Mark Banner best content maker and Brian
pwin for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions uh and whatever else happens
in the Chess World so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your
day